meanwhile it's left-hander tucker
davidson getting the ball uh for the
braves and davidson he wasn't even on
the postseason roster until game two
runner at first went on for carlos
correa who's batting third in the order
tonight
brandly elite at first o2 on the wave
comebacker taken by ozzy steps on second
there's one over the first double play
and a solid start for tucker davidson of
the atlanta braves astros send the
minimum to the play at the top of the
first inning no runs no hits no errors
and none left we play to have an inning
astros nothing and the braves coming up
when we come back from valdez on the
mound for the astros and he wasn't very
good in his game one world series start
uh didn't make it out of the third
inning gave up five runs and they are
loaded now for adam duvall
first pitch to adam
swung on a fly ball to deep right that's
carrying back there to the wall
grand slam
touch em all adam duvall it is
four-nothing atlanta
and now it's alex bregman's turn runners
lead off first and second
the 2-2
and bregman lines this one toward right
center field that's headed for the gap
and that's going to get down and go all
the way to the wall guriel around third
he will score tucker will stop at third
breckman with an rbi double his second
hit of the world series and it is 4-1
atlanta
so two-minute scoring position now with
one out for martine maldonado two and
two the count to maldonado runners lead
off second and third the pitch
and martine lifts it into center field
duvall going back on it and makes the
catch a step onto the warning track both
runners will tag as tucker scores on the
third goes bregman a sacrifice fly for
maldonado and it's 4-2 braves just what
the doctor ordered the astros to half
the lead right away
for himself with two down and a runner
at third base
there's the 2-2 on the way
got him looking strike three
fastball into the inning
astros get two of those runs back to the
gave up in the bottom of the first
inning
two runs two hits no errors one left off
to the bottom of the second we go braves
four astros two dansby swanson will lead
things off for atlanta against from
valdez looking for better
returns in the bottom of the second
inning
the one two
that's a ground ball up the middle to
his left correa he snags it spins throws
to first in time excellent play by
carlos correa piro wedding and getting
rid of the ball just nicking the runner
so one out of nobody on for tucker
davidson 0 for six as a hitter as a big
leaguer with six strikeouts the o2 swing
and a miss goes down on three pitches
here and at the top of the order for the
astros altuve leading things off here's
the 3-2
and it's a hard hit ball to the left
side of the infield bobbled by swanson
and altuve is going to reach should have
been and out dansby swanson the
shortstop
bungled it
and altuve reaches with nobody out here
in the third second error swanson has
made in this world series
and the astros have the potential go
ahead run
all of a sudden coming to the plate in
carlos correa here's the 3-2 from chavez
this one's driven to left-center field
that's going to get down altuve will
score
getting to third bases brantley it's a
sliding double by correa it's four to
three
a bullet from carlos correa so here's
guriel right-handed batter
braves lead 4-3 top of the third first
pitch grounder up the middle swanson's
got it goes to first base out but the
run scores all of a sudden just like
that it's four to four
now rudders at first and third two down
for alex bregman 2-0 pitch
bregman hits one high in the air to left
coming in eddie rosario looking up he's
under it and he's got it
that's the third out
this could be the last time these fans
that are packed into truest park see
freddy freeman in a braves uniform here
at home free agent to be
lined up in the 3-2 on the way
hit well to deep right center field way
back this one is flying and that is a
monster mash out of freddy freeman
freeman barreled it into the seats over
the braves bullpen and it's 5-4 atlanta
freddie leading off the bottom half of
the third with a homer to get the lead
right back that is so huge
tough play bregman bare hand got it
good play by alex brickman
aldonado with zach grinky on deck
it's one up the middle and to his left
aldi's has it throws it
and freeman has to dig it out on a
routine throw all these bounces another
one over there one out and the astros
will send zach grinky to the plate now
who of course started for the astros
last night and at the plate batted twice
and got a hit hit one sharply up the
middle in his first at bat one for two
chavez oh one pitch
is driven to right field and that's a
base hit a sharp one hopper to right
field and grinky has a pinch hit single
how about that might be the last one
ever
by a pitcher right in the world series
that's crazy
that'll load him up for martine
maldonado 3-1 to maldonado
and he takes it way inside for ball four
and the astros tie it on the bases
loaded walk
correa comes home it is five to five
and now marwin gonzalez is going to
pinch it for jose or keaney
pitch on the way
and morrowind lifts this one in a
shallow left field rosario coming in
it'll drop in front of him for a hit
guriel scores bregman scores it's a
two-run single for the pitch header
gonzalez and the astros lead for the
first time today
seven to five
well two bay's been on base once scored
once all together over three reached on
an error back in the third inning
runners go 3-2 got him swinging strike
three that's a big one had to happen so
riley's in scoring position with two out
and eddie rosario comes to the plate as
a tying run
two two
ground ball tap weekly back to bait time
fields it on the front slope of the
mountain it's part of the way to first
and shovels to guriel for the out
side retired riley stranded after a
two-out double
and after five innings in game five of
the world series astro seven braves five
there's alvarez over three two flyouts
and the strikeout and the one swung on
popped up down the left field line not
very deep on comes eddie rosario sliding
and made a catch in fair territory
eddie rosario comes up with another gem
down the left field line on a fluke
and that'll end the inning nice play
again eddie
and jack peterson is the pitch hitter
and peterson hits it off the hands pops
it up foul ground third base side
maldonado and bregman chasing it and
breckman runs it now
that'll bring up maldonado see if
maldonado might set on one
here's the 2-1
another curve pulls it through the left
side that's a base hit tucker around
third base throw in not a time astros
lead eight to five on the rbi single by
maldonado
he goes to second base on the throw and
a clutch hit with two outs for the
machete
there's chas mccormick pitch from smiley
swinging to miss strike three
got him with a curveball he gets through
the seventh but gives up a run one run
two hits no errors one left and the
braves are going to bring their infield
in for correa who is two for four with
an rbi double and a run scored
now the 1-0
and carlos strikes this in the left for
a base set altuve can walk home and the
astros have a 9-5 lead inning continues
for kyle tucker there's the 2-1 there's
a fly ball at a deep left eddie rosario
looks up and he's under it and eddie has
got it that's out number three another
run added for houston now it's travis
starneau who is two for three couple of
singles
2-2
swing and a miss
strikes it out on a high slider and the
inning is over
and jorge solaire
stands in one for four with a single
2-2
swing and a miss solaire goes down on a
high fastball and that is the ball game
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes